brendan dressed like little house on the
piccadilly cafeteria over there no i'm
an extra from [ __ ] yellowstone doug
what's up he looked like indiana jones
right
but
that's it yeah i don't know
wow
okay i didn't come with it on that okay
back off my broccolini
get your life together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
we can hear it deal put those on dog
put the cans on you got those hairs doug
you got those highway patrol glasses on
today
yeah baby
gang gang baby yeah baby
with the rat king i'll start doing rat
things baby
on top of the world baby what do you
know about corey santa hagan where'd you
buy that shirt from doug huh you don't
know [ __ ] about him what do you know
about cooper the sandman
who is that hey what comes out of a hip
baby i'll tell you that bootleg son you
know what i'm saying oh
tight moved hug
that extra appendage son you don't want
any of it you want that sleepy time
but is that a fake shirt is that what
you're trying to say i'm not sure if
it's fake or not i think that's the real
one
the box smelled like it had fentanyl in
it very chinese the box at least it
wasn't a snake this time
yeah you know who did that [ __ ] boy yeah
we know who did that stevie
what are you talking about your brother
tried to kill our friend theo what are
you doing yeah you little freaking
you know what i'm talking about your
little siamese christmas whistle
what do you do wait wait wait wait wait
let's talk about this what did bob do he
sent him a [ __ ] poisonous snake oh
right
did you confront him i'll blow air down
your face i'll blow air down your face
and make your ass play a song son i
don't mind it um
so did he said bring it did did he
really send the snake
yeah he did your little freaking petco
ass
i don't think it was a petco situation
y'all over there running a little
japanese petco i know what you're doing
now
um theo i had um yeah what would the
japanese petco be it'd be like all
reptili like like insects and
salamanders yeah yeah yeah yeah
but it's still like but it's like a
market because you also eat those things
there's like random bats flying around
and [ __ ]
it has that one cat that's armed just
goes up like that
it's like and it's also a wet market
[Laughter]
and steam room i'll take a salad man or
some soup
nah just showing love to my boy san
hagen man he's one of you know obviously
he's one of all of our favorites i think
so that's my guy man you know i had to
do i knew a dude i know it is i get that
where it says the sandman i gave him the
nickname i said you did it yeah
no i am i've known him since he was 16.
oh okay i gave him the nickname oh you
ordered a sandwich
and then and then yeah and then i had
cricket wireless at the time and then
yeah i got a sandwich he's like oh i
like the sand man and then here we are
so i love these kind of i love these
kind of t-shirts because i used to i
knew a dude who used to like had a
t-shirt company way back in the day it
wasn't a company what he would do is
like whatever was happening in the news
they would make t-shirts and then like
fly to like a city like when barry bonds
was like going through all that trouble
oh yeah he would they would make sure
it's like [ __ ] berry bonds then they
would fly to wherever yeah this guy
sounds like a real piece of [ __ ] but
they would be in the they'd be in the
parking lot and hustling and just
hustling and selling these shirts now
he's making go brandon shirts yeah that
kind of stuff going to theo's town hey
brendan i had another female reach out
to me oh yeah
oh yeah you're the you're the theo i met
another one of your ladies
steve the theory i was trying to figure
out what your dick size was
she was trying to figure it out no i
asked and she said oh she's almost the
holidays what are you doing and she said
that it's a coke
a coke can wow that's how thick his
penis is wow it's a small coat no he
said that's thick that's like that
liquid death that's how thick theo is i
think it's one of those little cans
though i think it's one of those kid
cans yeah the one the ones you get on
the airplane no that's girth no it's
like a red bull kid
it's airplane size thank you eric it's
definitely
that's a thick girth man you think i'm
carrying a recyclable between my legs
out of your mind you got a thick one man
so wait wait wait so girls they're
[ __ ] theo are called i don't know why
they confide in me
it's like i'm like their friend they can
confide in like oh have you talked to
him and i'm like why are you bothering
me and then you're the middle man man
you're like the tour but i don't know
what to do
and they want to get on that dick bus
to get to the king you gotta go through
stevie yeah i like this oh so i have
like a like one of those clipboards yeah
you like the schedule
in front of the bus you're the one that
gives the landmates out though yeah
there you go and the wristbands the
wristbands i don't want to be that guy
there you're that guy
i don't want to be that guy i want to be
like you guys and then theo gets on the
bus why is everybody asian on this
[ __ ] thing
why does everybody here think we're
going to gamble something
whether we're smoking cigarettes
they going to bicycle casino
i don't know
the front of the bus on the mic uh hello
everybody uh to your left is uh
theo's
taint
i don't want to be that guy how do i get
out of that role guys i don't want to be
that guy it's too late good question
let's let's answer this for stevie do
you have you guys have i don't want to
be there for him yeah yeah quit
answering yeah yeah stop yeah anytime
you see any like the thing is theo steve
looks at his dms and he sees theo's dick
and he goes ooh
something they get it's clickbait it's
clickbait and then you get no way i'm
not going to partake in that because i
bet she'd even see my man's dick that's
what i would bet
i have a question brother
he's a gentleman
yeah how what i feel like you're doing
things like sexually online and you're
trying to like reframe it that i have
something to do with you yep what are
you guys talking about yeah it's like on
gas lighting no i kind of feel like if
you just google anything about
some you know dick and like something
weird theo comes up anyway you know what
i mean me yeah
how would you say
you go weird dick fetish and then theo
comes up you know in a clip
yeah but you guys are always sitting
together so this is you you're you're
tied at the hip that's interesting you
know what maybe i have an obsession just
because i want to know if he's like that
yeah yeah i knew it was coming everybody
theo we need to know tell us when to
stop feeling tell us when to stop
thinking it will end i guarantee you it
will end once you come out and just say
yeah i got this i got the salami give us
some centimeters you know what i'm
saying then i'll stop give us some
cinnamon he doesn't kiss him just do
that
bro i have a vegan slim jim brother okay
i have it's not even beef it's turkey
there's no meat on it
there's no meat on it
i mean there's meat on it but you gotta
chew around a little
yeah you got elite where it's lean it's
like the lean machine
look i'll tell you that's a problem i
could find meat on it but i don't think
a white person could
hey hey theo how was buffalo my mother
watches the show can we please stop
talking oh okay i'm trying to get you
out of it theo how was buffalo man
oh buffalo was good man uh do you see a
bunch of bee shop jerseys walking around
there
[Laughter]
i did see a lot of
a lot of stolen valor a lot of bishop
jerseys out there
homemade i know you only spent a short
time with the bills so they were
homemade brothers they were selling
those jerseys for a little bit man and i
haven't seen any royalties
look i'd have
and i'd have bought one man how was the
uh how'd the taping go man yeah it was
great man it was dope we we didn't film
thursday we shot two on friday two on
saturday thursday's crowd was insane i'm
all damn we didn't shoot this friday
crowd a little tired i was like all
right first one
and then friday was lit and then i told
the team because all my team produced
everyone i said i'm telling you get your
minds right saturday early show is going
to be the one like you think i'm like no
i'm [ __ ] telling you man and it was
nuts
packed packed jam-packed yeah stay in
the room it could have went any better
could have went any better
clothes they're not closed
[Laughter]
closed
did they have clothes on i'm just
wondering stevie always making it sexual
man yeah yeah you know what i'll stop
doing that guys
i want you to be you steve yeah
that's what you're into dog yeah yeah i
feel like we're setting up for a
wrestling mat a second wrestling match
for stevie between stevie and theo yeah
no i've already taken my recipe no i did
it already i don't want to partake in
that either you gotta be naked how about
it's his turn right i've also looked
like he's like steel's gotta have a
banana hammock on though yeah
a thong with a good feeling yeah
let me see that song
[Music]
that's theo
we had to spell it like theo
it's a theong you look like megan
stallion from the back it'd be like ufc
one jiu jitsu versus wrestling yeah
stylistic matchup oh you're gonna get a
boy
hammock and we'll talk oh
well that's not fair because you're very
you have to make different rules that's
very ethnic of you a wrestler is trying
to stay off his back right so you know
what i mean because if i have you on
your back that's points for me being jiu
jitsu you want to be on your back yeah
there's too many details steve you just
get in there and oil up dog
yeah
so today look i just want to say this
man i'm happy to be in here with you
guys i'm excited to be i'll be in at
least for the next few weeks heading
into the holidays and into the new year
so thank you guys for holding it down
man when i'm not over there are you
coming soon
yeah
when are you coming i'll be home soon
it depends on how you rub it steve
papa's coming home papa's coming home
he's petting you papa is your mom over
here by the screen yeah let him tuck
your head over here let me get his hands
on but don't hit the tv yeah but don't
touch it yeah
yeah a little more bob good stevie
i like how steve is like
like rose in the titanic on the couch
[Laughter]
[Music]
i don't like what you're doing right now
hey i don't like what you're doing
oh whatever whatever that is whatever
that is
that's demeaning what you're doing
[Music]
stop that
that's driving me crazy whatever your
little shoulders are driving me crazy
don't do that
put your little shoulders over here
bubby i did it already i did it all
right it's over i was being vulnerable i
did it
wait wait wait wait wait wait oh my my
mom was pissed she was told that uh
chili's story last week
mama is not happy
did not talk to me well tell her
thieving ass
i was like you know what stealing i just
remember oh criminal ass shot i got [ __ ]
from my thing too well you should have
yeah oh i'm getting a lot of i'm getting
a lot of red bull things i i need to we
got to erase that can we erase that
whole way too long no no erase the
episode trust me i wish we could my mom
was not happy people were saying steve
that's not the you gotta that's wrong
and people in my program
were saying stuff too
people sent that program people send me
pictures steve are they going like i'm
doing a steve and i got two rebels in
their hands can i make an announcement
guys
i've stopped that behavior
i'm no longer doing that behavior i'm
not taking red bull and and now i can't
do it good for you yeah because they
called me out and i stopped i stopped
okay this is what we do here i stopped
this is like intervention yeah we make
people better you know we make people
better
we're working on theo's racism but we'll
get there
sometimes in your dna does yeah
sometimes it's just who you are
i wouldn't be racist if it wasn't for
all these other people
what are you talking about
[Music]
different people steve can we get the
show going let's go this is the show all
right hit it nick let's take a little
break from the shenanigans with the cats
crew cause man a lot of y'all out there
at coffee shops
scrolling the internet looking at some
strange stuff you know what i'm talking
about i've been there myself got a dark
roast and looking at some creepy stuff
you want people to look at what you're
looking at huh using the internet
without expressvpn is like leaving your
laptop exposed at that coffee shop while
you run to the bathroom everybody's
looking at your stuff all right don't do
that man every time you connect a
unencrypted network cafes hotels
airports any hacker on the same network
can gain access to your personal data
passwords financial details he stresses
you out done it it doesn't take much
technical knowledge to hack somebody
it's freaking easy kids are doing all
over the freaking place 12 year old
could do it a very smart 12 year old but
still man still
all right you need to use expressvpn
it's super secure all right it's super
secure it's easy to use fire up the app
and click one button to get protected
your boy here use it every freaking time
works on all devices phones laptops
tablets and more so you can stay secure
all the time secure your online data
today by visiting
expressvpn.com kats that's exp
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n.com
cats and you can get an extra three
months free free
expressvpn.com cats
is there something interfering with your
happiness that's a great question and
you have to ask yourself it can't just
be me asking you
is there something interfering with your
happiness
and when you have that answer you have a
good place to start
and uh somebody sometimes you need help
answering and sometimes a place called
better help can help you answer that's
right
visit betterhelp.com
k-a-t-s that's better h-e-l-p and join
the over 1 million people who have taken
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional i
have used betterhelp
it's a good way if you don't have a
therapist at the moment or in person
where you can get one to talk to on the
phone on facetime on zoom etc
betterhelp.com
this podcast is sponsored by better help
and king and the sting listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
k-a-t-s
this is our show where have you been
this is the show this is what we do
every week
i have one question stevie what are you
going to replace the behaviors with
because i've been learning that i got to
replace behaviors if i have old
behaviors right what are some things
you're replacing
you can't replace it with like nicotine
and and all your masters that's a good
question the first thing that popped up
in in my head was
maybe without taking credit or or
showing off i could just
do something for someone like on the
street like i'll get him a coffee
[Music]
coming up for steve i think this is all
going to work out oh let's put that out
yeah yeah yeah yeah because i feel a red
bull lawsuit coming yeah right
because he got wings
you know i'll take the sponsorship yeah
yeah but it's totally like the most
docile game instead of x games it's like
the most docile games ever it's just
like
creep games it'd be sex games
games
it'd be sex games yeah loitering yeah
triple x games
loitering oh my god i want to be the
announcer on that one and steve is uh
standing in front of a liquor store
uh no one does it better than stevie
weeby from korea
i hit it
let's continue yeah eric finally got a
little racist out here all right
so we got really job
you come from a criminal family and you
over here give him doug don't give him
dab i thought
i thought chin was bad i don't give a
chin's a gang member man remember you
over here with the sopranos over here
well that's my mom man that's mrs
goddard your mom was a product of it
did she at least see the cartoon she's
immortalized yeah i sent her the cartoon
not
not
in the cartoon i thought it was cute i
thought it was funny can i get some
facial hair on my character though who's
drawing this [ __ ] i love it
they make feel cute i'm all [ __ ] ugly
i was cute as [ __ ] as a kid man
well
i was man i got the pictures
stevie's still cute i think yeah there
you go there you go which we still have
to bring in our baby pictures we said
that a couple weeks ago
oh i'm gonna flex what's that for again
what's the baby pictures for again we'll
put our vote out there cutest baby
okay eric driving in his baby picture he
was like oh i want to see you damn here
we go i want to see your baby pictures
yeah
uber driver
president
eric was head of the debate club at four
years old yeah
it is what it is you know
you can talk about cartoons i had to let
them know
i had to educate you i had to educate my
first grade class
so we got baby they should make a uh
they should chisel us into a rock baby
because we're freaking mount crush more
dawg
oh man
so we got some great submissions today
good topics to cover but first someone
sent in what they believe is the
originator of the term island boy that
was very interesting
this is king and it's kind of
oh the old setup episode 89. everyone
wants to be theo's friend cause i'm
curious we didn't have a lot of them
growing up you know so you see him you
get fired up hey vietnamese people you
know what y'all doing oh steve was on
the show back then like you know who
island boy yeah
you know who you call island yes they
probably like that yeah they do
everybody does yeah everybody is the
island boy i don't i bet you don't see a
lot of island boys in nashville
no not really it's a little bit more
i feel like i have no idea what it's
like that's it that was you guys oh
start the island boy you should
trademark that copyright field brendan
dressed brendan dressed like little
house on the piccadilly cafeteria over
there no i'm an extra from [ __ ]
yellowstone dog what's up he looked like
indiana jones right
but
that's it yeah i don't know
wow
okay
i didn't come with it on that okay
i'll take the l
i like how you aborted though yeah i'm
like yeah i don't want to do because i
saw the flannel and i was like no you
messed it up
this shit's pretty lit though
eric now now you know stevie when you
look at these men right here these grown
men what do you see
who
me and theo doug
well i look up to you guys cause uh you
know you guys hustle you guys you know
work work hard at your your your craft
uh you you paid your dues you're
constantly working on your [ __ ] and yeah
i look up to that
and do you feel like god has a plan for
you
[Laughter]
anytime theo gets religious i go where
is this going uh in what way like what
do you mean theo what do you mean what
do you mean what do you mean this is how
altar boys get molested
just like this
don't bring that up
what are you doing you know an easy way
to get to heaven stephen
behavior whatever you're implying i'm
not doing any of that i can just heal's
one of those guys
brother theo have some things to say
this evening uh can brother theo come to
the altar and
well
to answer yeah maybe yes yes yes maybe
yes theo maybe yes
i want you to be weak i have to
i have to do the action though and walk
start doing the the footwork that's all
you're doing the footwork yeah you're
doing the footwork jesus you're doing
god's work right now yeah yeah steve's
out here feeling confident about his
stand-up he's out here like
i went up a few times theo i've been
hurt i've been hearing about it man a
lot of people i'm trying to work through
i'm trying to learn from you guys yeah
so you're doing good remember where you
were three months ago you were afraid to
even do it no i i'm excited doing it now
i have it yeah i'm having fun yeah i
love it yeah there you go i text bobby
after you got a stage at my show i said
bobby
brother just went up i'm telling he
could do this man what did he say he
gave me an emoji from middle finger he
doesn't like it i'm gonna take his act
he doesn't like it
don't you don't take his actions
edit that out there
time stamp that all right
there you go speaking of right here
asian men who god has a plan for here's
a nice segue submission from riley mower
good friend okay
hey man what is up guys riley mao here i
thought he looked i am japanese korean
hawaiian
and i'm still a virgin
oh what's up stevie what's up eric
what's up brandon what's up theo miss
you dude
um
hey i've got a quick kingdor sing it for
you guys
so
sesame street just introduced their
first asian american muppets
um i won i just wanted to get your
guys's opinion on it uh kingdor sting it
i personally think
it's wonderful um because now
all of you
young
asian men like me
can uh
you know grow up one day and
be uh be a muppet oh squid games wasn't
enough for you thanks guys love y'all
gang gang buzz buzz yeah bruce lee yeah
squid game enough chun li yeah you know
you had a representation street fighter
like a [ __ ] yeah yeah now we
need a muppet yeah man thank you for the
submission raleigh mal yeah let's see
this muppet
yeah what which one's the asian hey
asians congrats on getting a muppet of a
show nobody [ __ ] watches i bet you
want to ask what makes the muppet asian
skin tone
that's the asian muppet see but that was
my thing it would look racist if the
eyes were super squinty which yeah
that's racist so what's the is it the
the person voicing is asian or like i
don't get i'm up it's the color of me
what makes it asian his eyes we got a
squishy oh but does she talk
you know that's where it gets a little
racist yeah why'd they put eyes under
the eyes
that's his eyebrows [ __ ]
that's his eyebrows
hey man i take your face to that bro our
monitor's blurry here no no no
those are his eyebrows
that's messed up man
we're on like a six by eight here
[Laughter]
the racist cops just said uh why you
know why you got pulled over theo do you
know why you got pulled over
and he's like with a monitor i can't see
[Laughter]
oh and now he's off now he like they
turned his mother hey come back theo he
cut the feed
but honestly you know i i got two young
kids who the [ __ ] watching sesame
street not much no one really [ __ ] you
know
can we get this guy playing can we get
this guy laid though at least right chin
riley mal yeah let's do a whole thing
you guys i don't think he wants to theo
knows him about anybody you touch his
back he busts i guess
[Laughter]
you got to help me out on this man we
got to look out for our agents
you got to look out for your brother
there i'm teaching the game what i
learned can you guys do this you got to
bring it in real quick hook him up hook
him up i'll do my best yeah you don't
want to reach out you don't want to
scare them well how can we sting this it
wouldn't make any sense
what are we going to stay like
that's the more racist thing sting it
asian muppet we're like no this is great
king it king
well here's my thing is they need to
move this sesame street has gotten
they i mean they need to take that i
don't know where this street is at now
it looks like he's in the damn hamptons
they need to move the [ __ ]
over to new york city over to 12th and b
or something over there in alphabet city
yeah where everybody's out there thought
and they got some pimps out there and
they got some real mfr's out there
shooting uh abcs right into their veins
yeah get a little dangerous out in that
[ __ ] i'm with it man make it more real
also i tried showing my kids sesame
street they're used to pixar and this
high level [ __ ] my son was like what the
[ __ ] is this
are they are they made out of carpet
that's your bougie ass picture
you're so damn bougie that's what the
problem is you got your [ __ ] yeah
you wouldn't be where you are right now
you know who's stinging it i bet count
chocula ooh they got rid of him yep
did they
i think yeah i don't think count
chocolate isn't there anymore yeah i
think that was like cultural
appropriation so they got ready they
still make this cereal though
do you all remember blacula
yes yeah it was one of those
exploitation films yeah it's a black
dracula oh from the 70s yeah yeah yeah i
missed that one
my thing is how are you going to call it
sesame street an obvious asian condo
is finally just here we go
sesame chicken street
and we're all cool with that
i'm just saying pay to people sesame oil
street chin don't be quiet on this one i
agree with you stand up for our people
are you saying like sesame street
you guys need reparations man from
sesame street unacceptable
but there was like two chinese
restaurants on sesame street you know
what i mean relax it ain't asian street
it was a long time there was a
laundromat you know what i mean it was
like everything was out there popping
yeah y'all need to sue them dude in a
year that place should be you you should
be chin henson y'all need to sue that
dude
if you put chin on anything it makes it
racist you gotta stand up for yourself
man but honestly my name sounds very
very asian so it is
what's worse ching or chin
ching sounds even more yeah ching is
more asian oh bro we got it got dicey
and dallas i got my favorite whiskey
nica whiskey you say it wrong you're in
some world ikka yes
fantastic whiskey but you said when i
were at the bar when i ordered at the
barge go i'll take that one you guys
which one come on bro you know which one
you know
you know which one give me that and give
me that n-word whiskey
you guys say it's the term of a dear man
give me my
oh okay
all right this guy said i'm not doing
this
it's not even engaging we've done it
before yeah yeah so we king that right
we king
i sting sesame street just they've never
they've they've never [ __ ] been
current in a hot section all right all
right but all kings
do you think this is still a viable way
to communicate with children or is this
a has this ship sailed no i think that
kids enjoy all kinds of nonsense
i mean if it's entertaining mr rogers if
they're singing yeah mr rogers was cool
yeah the electric company and all that
stuff i just i think it's it is what it
is sometimes you hear about parents
talking about some that they'd be like
whatever the hot cartoon is that all the
kids are watching tigers whatever it is
and then and then they the kids want to
watch it like ad nauseam so it's just it
is what it is coco melon is a big one
right now
uh let's see what this guy asks
hey guys it's connor from new hampshire
i have a king inner stinger for you over
the weekend there was this crazy rock
chick and she was playing at her show
and had to go to the bathroom and
instead of stopping the show like a true
professional she just grabbed somebody
from the crowd brought him up and pissed
all over them
so i got a little style is that
something you guys would ever do at a
show and feel be honest would you ever
lay down and take that salty salty
waterfall to the face let me know
king it or sting it gang gang buzz buzz
kiss kiss piss piss
first question was she hot yeah yeah
that's the first question she's pretty
sure i don't think so but that's the
only way theo gets hard now right still
that's what i'm hearing this is her yeah
it's like billions
we can't tell from that picture we gotta
you should have a better picture nick
we'll watch the video and then i'll
bring up a picture of her
but did the guy know this just happened
oh she's been hard too
there
oh she's pissing dude it's rock and roll
that [ __ ] is
watching the jet stream
oh my god she had to piss so hard
that's a super super
but she put pushing too hard i feel like
some dookie's gonna come out
that's how it comes out
i thought it was she was a super that
was more thinner than that yeah that was
a lot that was a whole waterfall a damn
parade horse
[Laughter]
yeah dude
she like one of those no no one of those
police horses in new york you know what
i mean pissed hard that was hard she
like that's a highway patrol horse piss
right there yeah what the fire station
that you represent
god damn god dawg let's see yeah damn
she ladder 7080 right what the dead kick
out of her mind
bro how how only way
let's let's get some answers steve be
what you think uh that was actually cool
the context because uh you know it
seemed like a rock concert you know my
thing is [ __ ] that how how fast would
a male be canceled if he got his dick
out and pissed on the girl's face real
quick
well he's in prison for life yeah
is he she's pretty hot is that she looks
better there yeah she's really hot yeah
this is like you can't listen to the
peanut gallery over here on hot girls no
meatball went like this
she's bad yeah she is i mean i'm not
gonna let her piss on me but she's bad
her last name's yuri stuff i know that
was the funniest thing too close to
urethra yeah
yeah i thought you were going to say
barista like she's like you know what i
mean either way she's she's surprised
look at that psychotic the brains of it
but what do you i mean what's going
through somebody's brain if they're
doing this type of stuff trying to get
lit bro it's a [ __ ] rock concert
travis scott killed somebody
yeah
this is a lot i'm just i you know it is
what it is if you're what do you mean
what does that mean because this is very
fetishy okay so how do you like when do
you know you want somebody to pee on you
i i just think she had to pee hard she
did nothing no
this ain't on her but maybe she likes
pee this this is obviously her thing she
wants that's in the first time she's
pissed yeah that's not the first time
she's peed on her but what if she pooed
that's what i'm saying i thought what's
worse poor peace what do you think what
do you do what's worse
okay hold on now king of stinging
[ __ ] help me out no don't go to chin on
this one help me out man so you think
that there's you tell us steamer you
want to get you want to
check the [ __ ] on your chest or pee on
it guys why are we talking about gross
stuff on the chest it's called a hot car
let me let me think about it let's go on
to the next one huh you want to think
about it let me think about it we'll go
to the next one we gotta come back to
this she's attractive i'm i'm gonna
sting that though but also you had a
rock concert i don't know what kind of
music yeah let's sting it let's think
we're moving on theo we're moving on
look i would like to say something i
think if you if somebody is very thirsty
you're out in the desert you are
in a place like that or you're in a
plane crash or something and you gotta
serve a little out your body that's
different yeah or like a jellyfish
jellyfish stuff yeah just wine and dine
in anybody in general admission this
[ __ ] is just yeah yeah yeah but he you
know what he could have been vip meet
and greet like like brendan does you
know what i mean brendan out here doing
stuff and then he agrees we don't know
what's happening i don't i don't be
pissing on people
i'll take your eye out man
i came up with my answer i like the poo
better oh
i have a weird thing to be a freak
you know what the stevia oh my no hold
on you know what stevia is stevia scat
babe oh man
this is your fault theo you you you
asked him the question yeah this is your
fault and now live with your
consequences okay
live with your consequences you don't
have to keep it we can edit this out no
we're going to keep yourself free are
you a scout baby king interesting here
we go black friday season is officially
here happy
holidays
and with it has come mvmt's biggest sale
of the year it just so happens to be the
biggest sale they've ever had yep
yep mvmt has introduced some of their
most innovative and premium materials
yet this year
as well as some of the most epic special
edition releases
ocean plastic edition watch made from
100 recycled ocean plastic and features
a solar powered dial
that's a piece of nature on your wrist
dude that's like having damn uh
poseidon's menstrual cycle on your damn
wrist son
made with uh elevated and unique look
glossy and ultra resistant material
lighter and stronger than steel
it's time
nvmt's everscroll blue light filtering
glasses are a must have
made with a hundred percent acetates
and stainless steel
the most stylish way to protect your
eyes
shop mvmt's biggest sale of the year
before the rest at mvmt.com use code
cats at checkout get free shipping and
free returns
by going to mvmt.com
kats
go to mvmt.com
cats
to get these holiday rarities uh this is
a cats in the wild actually someone saw
chin and brendan in a road rage incident
and they thought evidently it was eric
that was filming
oh damn that dude got a sword
oh damn that big boy backing down
that flat shirt is hot beat his ass
[Laughter]
yeah he got you [ __ ] up bro
oh what's he getting done he's got a
sword
oh [ __ ]
oh that guy said oh i'm [ __ ] out
what was the second weapon a gun he's
protecting those [ __ ] stores you know
what's crazy about that man i remember
back in the day you'd be playing
basketball and then like you know it
gets heated and then somebody's like i'm
going to my trunk
that's like a real thing people be doing
i'm going to my trip so this guy that's
semi-automatic that ain't like a handgun
look at that look at that gun man hey
did did you guys see the fighter sean
strickland he recorded on instagram live
this guy's like road raging with him and
sean strickland goes pull over and he
goes do you have any guns or knives he
goes no guns no knives i'll get out of
the car and [ __ ] you up there's no guns
or knives you have any guns the guy goes
i got bullets shawn's like i'll [ __ ] you
and drives off
i like that yeah yeah you throw a bullet
as hard as you can shoot a bullet man
that's true it's still a bullet yeah but
that but that's weird though because can
the other guy be like you know
like if if i was in a road rage
situation i'd be asking let me see your
ears
you know i need to see you are you okay
you got training but you want to talk to
me you got training you want to talk all
that [ __ ] you want to talk all that [ __ ]
no but that's like
a trained killer
you're the one that's [ __ ] with him i
know but you're a trained killer but you
want to be like do you got anything that
can like balance the the lower the
playing
field a gun
i'm not getting out the car man but you
want to talk all that [ __ ] this way
shouldn't talk [ __ ] yeah this is that's
that's why you shouldn't talk [ __ ]
either because somebody might have a gun
i don't talk [ __ ] neither does sean
strickland this guy was looking for you
do brendan and that dude is dressed like
that dude dressed like the british all
come from the british old picnic
collection
oh he was wait wait all he was missing
was his indiana jones hat boom there it
is
brought
[Laughter]
but why you have that kind of gun in
your trunk yeah you're driving around
with like not even you driving around
with freaking rambo guns these [ __ ]
be crazy yeah but that crazy rittenhouse
brought an ak [ __ ] or what do you
bring ar-15
damn yeah but he it's not like he was
going to the store and then he was like
oh let me get my ar-15 and go do this
other thing he planned that out and went
and did it this guy's just driving down
the street and uh a asian dude pulls a
samurai sword out it's all weird you
know what it's all sweet i'm actually
with this dude getting his gun you know
what i'm saying
i just
thank you
now you're talking logically thank you
finally for once right holy smokes
what's up an uber for weapons that pulls
up with whatever weapon they each decide
to fight ooh that'd be dope yeah
yeah i think that i like it
uh we got another kingdom sting it
someone saw uh stevie this one's kind of
meta stevie skateboarding
[Music]
how did they even do that i don't know
how they did it but that's insane and
why is the kid crying in the background
i don't know it's a weird tic-tac but
this is weird i don't even know how they
might work i'm gonna i'm gonna sting
that i just thought it was very clever
of them that said it was stevie escape
all right i'll give that uh we got some
more debate clubs okay uh so they all
can be winners
[Laughter]
oh damn
mr still your man avoid nate thompson
right here that plays for uh
philadelphia flyer okay
what up king of the state it's your boy
jaker got a little debate club for you
guys today
so little nas x he was just named gq man
of the year um i'm curious to know who's
your guys's man of the year so brendan i
need you to stop licking your lips theo
get your hand out of your jaw
stevie
don't even come at me with cartoon
characters those aren't real people and
eric stop reading the comments bro we
love you all right yeah see uh looking
forward to what you guys got to say gang
gang buzz buzz
see steve
yeah i don't know what you want to start
first
look at how everybody's all sensitive
right now no i'm not saying that yeah
i got several of them thank you for the
for the uh
video brother i think there's a this is
a good question
yeah who you got in mind deal
i don't know i mean i have my freaking
hand in my pants right now it's insane
he knew it yeah
and i'm licking my lips what's the
criteria here what are we looking for
whatever you want man of course you can
be an actor a musician whoever
somebody we know not your friend who
gets you red bulls
tom hardy
why vet him too that was trash no but i
like him bro after all this [ __ ] you
gonna freaking give it to a white dude
after all they've done to y'all
he's english at least oh steven yeon
stephen yawn that's a great one who's
that
yes he was on uh
he did a freaking zombie movie yeah
walking dead [ __ ] dead i like that
guy
what about the guy from
stephen
what about the guy from squid games nah
stephen brand new stephen i like the guy
from the what's the marvel movie oh the
shanxi
they offered that to him by the way he
turned it down i really yeah i wonder
why he turned it down who you going with
theo
it's tough man man of the year or men of
the year which one is it uh
nas x got named men
uh he was one of the men of the year but
this guy asked who's your man of the
year
we can listen to a couple we got some
it's been a tough year yeah it's hard i
can only think of people i don't like
yeah like it'd be like fouchy
you know what i mean it's not colin
kaepernick it is not newsome
right
yeah man of the year that's the yeah
it's not is it theo it's not theo
because he don't come in the office i
would go a few of them i i'd say and
obviously oh of course i'd go with a few
of them i'd go number one dana white for
throwing fights on during the middle of
the pandemic the only sport to do it
that was gangster's point that's been
huge that's been oh dude it saved my
life and then there's also with the
fight island too during the fight that's
what he did yeah
domestic disputes imagine people seeing
they they seeing other people beat each
other they not beating their spouse boom
they're a man or woman doing the lord's
work
i give it to joe rogan for fighting
against all this [ __ ] uh
covet culture [ __ ]
going against cnn shutting them down
bringing a cnn doctor on lighting his
ass up
i give to aaron rodgers aaron rodgers
for doing the lord's work there's a
bunch man i can keep going if you want
kyrie irving
but dude he not take his money i don't
know everything about it did he not take
his money no he just refused to play
but he don't get his money
no he didn't he didn't he did not refuse
to play he's not allowed to play well he
refused the vaccination yeah yeah but he
yeah so he is losing money but he got so
much money that it's not really kind of
set that's a good point you don't play
basketball bad enough that's what i'm
saying yeah you don't want it yeah
go ahead eric he might retire i think
he's gonna you know
until they change the things i don't
know man this is this is just a tough
one well he named like four or five i
can keep going
here's a couple i gotta i mean i would
say look the island boys on this show
you guys man uh i would put all y'all as
men at a year maybe a group
and then i would maybe go glover to
share a bro that dude went in the
freaking belt at 41 42
42. bro that guy's story is amazing uh
jesus christ
he's in the running every year for sure
yeah
who else dude
i don't know probably a couple of
diversities
[Laughter]
praise god bro uh yeah no one here
not even one hour don't have one eric
don't even have one i think i'll think
about it we'll we'll come back
you still stuck on that indiana jones
thing
i'm gonna think of it he's like it's the
plastic bring it back around shirt the
hat i'm gonna come up with something
y'all oh dexter the new dexter is back
that's good bro [ __ ] daxter the new
yellow stone son season four is litty
like is
[Music]
everybody watch squid games yeah that's
on netflix
dude you gotta be richer to buy netflix
wait wait but you also have netflix no i
don't you have all of them yeah you do
you have food
you ain't [ __ ] shopping [ __ ]
no he
[Laughter]
yeah
i don't have money i have all of them
i mean it's 2021 man you can find
anything out there lifestyle creep i got
12 [ __ ] subscriptions
now i'm rich because i like yellowstone
oh you rich [ __ ] right with your
halloween costumes and your yellowstone
on the tv
but what's it about what's the whole
series about it's montana and uh john
dutton owns a a huge like ranch huge
ranch
and then it's basically it's like narcos
but in montana so then all these other
different families and people are trying
to take it over yeah it's super white
it's dope
it's montana that's why they did it like
that how can we do a show and make it
all white there's a black cowboy it's a
black cowboy we'll do it in montana
there's a black cowboy
there's no i got a man of the year dude
oh god [ __ ] up
the president of rwanda bruh
oh uh
paul deep down me
this guy's name it's a little deep dive
dude rwanda is a tourist destination now
and it's like a happening spot
rwanda from the movie where they killed
everybody
the hotel room oh yeah i remember yeah
where samuel hansen or whatever killed
everybody in that [ __ ]
and now paul kongame oh paul
yeah he looks like that's my guy i am
captain
i i was gonna say that but i'm like in
my head i'm like that could be racist so
let's sit this one out i am captain
no that was his first role and then he
got booked as president
i was doing this [ __ ] and before that he
was a cab driver in minneapolis
[Laughter]
that's how easy that's how easy it is to
be president of rwanda that's how easy
it is
bro rwanda's a tourist destination man
you can get they got ice cream over
there
now what did this guy do theo yeah why
is he yeah there's no news here man he's
just not in there and changed it around
he's been there since 2000 bro he's been
there 21 years he's changing
man of the decade maybe [ __ ] dude yeah
you're right maybe it's decade all right
i'll quit
[Laughter]
i'll be back in a few weeks
and bring brendan's hat oh there it is
this guy's got a debate club for us ooh
what's good guys sammy j here i got a
debate club for y'all over the weekend
snl did a skit about joe rogan and uh
tim dillon weighed in he called it a
hacky
could have been funnier the show's going
downhill all of a sudden michael che
comes and goes
tim dillon
who
they start going back and forth and um i
just want to know who you all got we got
tim dylan on the left we got michael che
on the right gang buzz i'll probably say
opposite um
chase more of a left
right but uh everyone's familiar with
what happened here no i don't i don't
know what happened i don't know what
he's referring to all right so so
uh
saturday live did a skit uh instead of
sesame street it was ted cruz street and
then in the skit pete davidson plays joe
rogan and he and the i thought that was
the hackiest thing that wrote the rogan
like jokes is weak like you know i just
eat you know innerva vermectin or
whatever and i'm not a scientist but i
look like you know whatever oh
so
that and then so that clip was posted it
wasn't tim dillon made fun of it and was
like yeah they're all hacked on there
they're weak you know making the show
hasn't been good in [ __ ] years then
obviously michael chase the head writer
of saturn live right he's the head
writer he's just one of the writers no
he's head writer he's the head writer
now he's the he's been the head writer
for over a year now i didn't know so
he's the head writer so obviously he
took defense of that and then was like
tim dillon because they came up in new
york together like tim dillon and some
one fan was like yo he makes 190 000 a
month off patreon and he was like
congrats for him but like i don't care
if it's a zillion i know tim dillon he
ain't what you think he is he's a sweet
humble guy who really tried to stand up
and got nowhere became a media
personality because it's much easier and
we're all very happy for him but don't
get fresh tim
and then tim lit him up tim goes here's
the reality and he just did sell out the
beacon theater which is huge in new york
tim goes here's the reality i sell more
tickets than michael che ever has i
don't think he's allowed to use the
website for his job they're not if
you're silent live can't be on twitter
and i've built something on my own that
he could never do jay has done well for
a drunk who can barely read but his show
sucks and he knows it how the hell is
brendan reading so fast
yeah
can we can we get those ad reads like
that
the things that pay the bills can we get
that
you've been playing hide and go stutter
with us
well when he's passionate about it you
know what i mean
well joe's your homie dude you got to
stick that's your homie i i don't need
to offend joe like that's a
they're frying themselves joe doesn't
defend himself or a weak hacky joke like
the the skit wasn't i didn't everyone's
hating on the skit i thought the skit
was kind of funny the ted cruz street it
was fun is this but then
the rogan said with pete davidson
obviously i like pete i don't pete's not
writing those jokes right you're right
you can tell pete
realized the joke because you can tell
he's reading on stage did he feel
uncomfortable it made me uncomfortable
how bad it was like i don't know if
these people believe the things that
they're saying about joe i think that
like you know writers do no no i i don't
think so
i could tell
that writing style like it would like
they could actually go after him and be
funny and then we could be like that's
what tim said that's but that's tim's
point he's like you could have made
better jokes yeah that was funny right
that was that wasn't funny at all but
but how many comics talk [ __ ] about
silent life cause we all came up on it
so so many but i think with this
i mean you guys missed the point i think
michael che who dropped a special stay
on netflix going toe-to-toe with tim
dillon who's [ __ ] huge on the
internet
by his fans going towards michael chase
and like going to his instagram and
looking them up and stuff like that it
just brings awareness to michael chase
special michael j is a smart [ __ ]
dude beast rider too beast man good
comic so i think all he's doing is
getting hyped for his special oh it's
publicity yeah yeah
and that's why he was like
tupac yeah he was like i don't want any
smoke like tim's a good dude i want his
smoke yeah yeah that's all he's doing
just publicity for special and it
[ __ ] worked we're talking about it
tim dillon could be man of the year i
don't think an episode of this show i
mean in living color blows any of this
[ __ ] out oh yeah and uh i think it's sad
that the only people they even pick on
on this show anymore are white dudes and
russians so i'd love to see any of these
guys have a little bit of balls and make
fun of anybody well they don't they
don't it's the network like like
saturday live is a woke left show that's
all they should say
they should send a gift basket to donald
trump every week when he was in office
because without donald trump what would
they even be talking about but the
ratings still suck tim gets better this
show gets better no no but i'm saying it
resurrected the show at the time they
want to emmy after that baldwin went off
yeah people were talking about it so
it's like it was like you know did you
not want him in office or did you want
him because it made the show better but
now that but now what do you mean that's
what i'm saying so now it's like okay
he's gone now what are you talking about
michael chase out of there anyways in
the [ __ ] in a year he's out of there his
show on hbo
he won't be around much longer oh [ __ ] i
thought i mean i don't know it's their
[ __ ] i feel like did you ever want to be
on saturday life deal any desire to do
that oh i'm sure when i was a child you
know i wanted to and i was you know like
you would see chris farley's on there
eddie murphy
yep uh
who else
miller uh
the lady smelling her arm colin quinn
yeah harley quinn
no her name's uh
are they smelling her arms was uh
no uh molly shannon molly shannon molly
shannon will ferrell yeah
yeah i go way back though yeah way back
you talk about blue shield yeah
these people they're not doing nothing
with no balls on it
they're not doing nothing and that's why
the ratings suck at all that's why all
their ratings so they have to know that
whether they who whether whoever you
know tim or whatever it is they're not
doing nothing with no balls on it no
intensity tim's not saying anything we
haven't heard yeah tim's not saying
anything we haven't heard like
everyone's thinking that safe bites bro
all they're doing is making fun of
conservative whites and russians which i
just think at a certain point it's like
you don't have no [ __ ] balls
so you standing around touching your own
yeah yeah it should be called the show
should be called it's like an echo
chamber now you know it's just a weak
shot who watches tv anyway
people still watching stevie you tell
them
everyone watches youtube everyone
watches youtube and all these things
yeah
yeah but you know what though snl
actually lends itself to being a show
that's great for youtube because
everything is clips they do clips they
do clips on youtube yeah like they're
like actually i think the show's big i
think snl is bigger on the internet than
it is on well for for instance the clip
of kim kardashian has 5.5 million views
i'd rather watch more views they've
gotten gears oh she had a funny joke
about that though and her opening
monologue she was like you know i'm used
to 300 million people watching me so
this is like a quiet night with only
like nine million you know what i mean
so she's making it it's the truth but
you know it's just like like key and
peel too yeah they're the best oh man i
love camp on the internet
on the internet it's even bigger because
it's like millions of you but that's how
snl is they have these short clips they
can't mess with key and pew but you know
what here's what i say snl is kind of
like mcdonald's you know it's like it's
an institution yeah it don't mean it's
good for you it's just it's been around
for so long that we just are used to it
it's saturday night live you know
whether it's good or bad it's going to
be on no one cares they don't care about
the ratings good or bad it's just like
we're going to put that in that time
it comes on at 11 o'clock like it's
saturday night i know but what i'm
saying is there's you don't have to
worry about that show like going off or
on it's not at eight o'clock in prime
time it's not you know what i mean you
know what i like here i like your mind
this morning if people know what they're
getting they get there if you want that
you're different that it's like it's
like turning to cnn
i know what what agenda they're gonna
play yeah yeah some people i'm not i'm
never going there for comedy like i've
never turned that on to get a laugh not
anymore sometimes
i'm always surprised when i get like if
i'll see a clip and i'll be like oh they
got me with this one it's rare a lot of
times when i just if i just watch it i
just find myself being like oh man what
i like i like to watch the weekend
update because i want to see what like
whatever woke agenda they're trying to
push and sometimes they sometimes that's
the if anything has teeth it'll be on
the weekend update but everything else
is just kind of like and my thing is
like just be funny you know come up with
like the old sketches like the church
lady and the like you know they had
these like it was just like funny
moments that they would come up with
that had nothing to do with like some
sort of agenda
yeah so it's like i don't know
a lot of birds are
not even doing that well anyway some of
the birds i see look sick as hell out
there you've been at the zoo recently
the bird over there you can't he won't
even come by the edge they look sad well
i think the zoo is a good i think they
should be doing well at the zoo well
some of these birds been acting up too
they deserve to be in the [ __ ] zoo
bro hell yeah what else you got nick
a couple more debate clubs we'll close
it out with
hey guys i have a pretty decent debate
club for you i don't think it's been
discussed yet uh today eric was talking
about uh maybe we should up the age of
consent after you guys were talking
about older men dating younger women
i've uh always been into younger men
yesterday i turned 39. tomorrow i have a
28 year old coming over to see me
it's just a fetish i guess i have i
don't even know if you would call it
that it is but i have always in the back
of my head wondered is that appropriate
when's it going to be not appropriate
like um 11 year age gap for a hookup
fine but maybe even a relationship i
don't know like where
should we be talking here should i be
feeling guilty i don't usually i think i
would feel more guilty with people my
own age because then i feel like i'm
pretending to like them so yeah that's
not what you're into older women with
younger guys better talk singing buzz
buzz
king king at kingit hey it is what it is
you know but like of course yeah oh
you're into attractive 28 year old men
in their prime weird i know that's right
like jeff bezos into a bad [ __ ] who's
38 has her [ __ ] together big tits weird
no but here's the thing though the
problem
what she's talking about is like a
hookup do you and i think it goes both
ways it's a hookup do you right
but like what ends up happening though
is what ends up happening is like this
the girl guy situation and this is just
real [ __ ] i mean
don't be insulted well whatever i don't
care
get real here yeah here you know what
ends up happening is you have a little
bit you have to listen to that black out
thing
you have the situation of like uh ashton
kutcher he was with demi moore right
yeah all right she was way older than
him but he woke up one day and looked
over like ooh oh this [ __ ] is bad
without a mask on i'm with my auntie you
know what i mean and then he was like oh
i gotta go find some then he left her
and same thing nick cannon with mariah
carey he woke up and he was like oh [ __ ]
i'm 30 something and sometimes my knees
hurt my chick is like you know so it's
like it's fine now so like in this
situation 28 39 are they going to be
together 10 years so when he's 38 and
she's 49 no he's out and he's you know
i'm just saying that's what you when you
talk about if you're going to talk about
long-term relationships you have to
decide what you want to how how old it
works we're we got a big age group
what's age gap it's like 15 16 years
no but i i feel though but i do feel
like 30 see this is what i'm saying what
i was talking about before it's like you
don't want to talk about
like is the person too young because you
you don't want to get into this slippery
slope of being like we're going to tell
people when it's okay for them to date
because if 18 they can drive cars go to
war pay taxes and all this stuff
they should we you know there's a
mindset of like well they should be able
to decide who they want to have sex with
but as a society when we see a 40 year
old and a 19 year old all of a sudden we
start to go oh this is bad okay
but then you don't want to tell this 19
year old what they can and cannot do so
then it might be the other way then we
got to be like hey come on you're 40
what are you doing with somebody who
hasn't lived and has doesn't have
experience and all that stuff so where's
the shame come the shame comes on that
person
so then we then that's what i was saying
like then rage you can't raise the age
of consent because you'll be taking away
rights from people and nobody wants to
do that so then maybe it has to be the
other way we have to be like all right
you you can only the person has you have
to only have this age gap between your
age or something whatever it is like
that you know but i know a lot of
i know a lot of great
families that have the parents had a
large age for sure there's a lot of you
know you know so
in my family most of my family is in
recovery
yep and there's age gap
recovery there's 38 year age gap 38 oh
jesus
that's that's too much so we're all king
in it or what if only certain
restaurants you could go to if you have
a certain amount of age gap then you're
only allowed to go to certain eating
places that's what i'm saying it's a
slippery slope man so i i just think
that it's one of these kind of like
unspoken rules that we're saying like
you know hey
how like is does this person feel like
they don't have any experience do you
feel like you're taking advantage of
this stuff sometimes she's 22 23 there's
older souls that they're mature well
that's but it's okay
it's a case-by-case situation i totally
agree with that but you know i don't
know man it's it's a tough it's it's a
tough one to talk about because you know
and and and where am i speaking from i'm
an older guy i have my chicks younger
than me so i don't want to be talking at
home
eric get a little cup of warm milk and
start chatting hell yeah
he get a cup of tea start chatting
dropping knowledge dropping
nuts like he that much younger than me
okay
all three you [ __ ] old yeah
stevie pound them yeah you are hey who
so but theo's the second youngest in
here
no he's not yeah he is d steve oh that's
right so it's me steve theo then let's
edit it young let's edit this stuff out
young about the age and everything about
the age gaps and everything yeah yeah
feel good
though theo looks the youngest
i feel good i feel good for my age but
here's the thing though okay but but
steve also looks good for his age so if
steve walked in i still get carded i've
never seen it i still get it if steve
walked in with a 23 year old would we be
like what's up steve absolutely yeah you
know what i mean what are you doing man
i'm not supposed to be drinking alcohol
stevie what are you getting carter yeah
love don't have a couch oh
chewing tobacco
chewing tobacco nicotine because he
needs to always say love don't have a
calendar
there you go
yeah cousin doing 10 to 15 for [ __ ]
pedophilia huh
no i don't know what his issue he had
some he ended up with definitely with
some issues i don't think he had nothing
sexual for children but
he was definitely has had some tough
times god bless him too derek anyone who
lives that life quote is going to have
some tough times but you know but the
thing too is like experience is
important like hell yeah you know and
and it's weird how like even for like
when you're young you just know you just
don't know the things that you know
later i mean you know one way yeah
and i know i have a lot of i know a
bunch of dudes who are like in their 20s
and they always like they're like oh i
love older women and whatever that
dynamic is like young gravy bro young
gravy like some milfs you know but i
don't know if it would work but like
this young grades at last yeah like a
chef musician chef
he's a white rapper he
theo bringing up young gravy is kind of
what kicked off our whole search that
found little brows really he he's just
he's the milf hunter
young gravy dude
yeah but does he want to be in
relationship wrong with that yeah yeah i
there
a
don't think it's again we are not there
is nothing wrong with you either way
stevie you're 50 or whatever what's the
youngest
i'm not 15. edit that out
what's the youngest i'm in my 40s what's
the youngest
late
29 30 that those are good ages yeah i
agree yeah that's gravy right there
phoebe you could be 30 years maybe a
beautiful young man he he has some bars
let him do his thing he likes older
women yeah yeah well let him do his
thing let him do his thing so does keanu
reeves he like older women he would do
their thing
him and lil wayne had a little drop a
couple months but yeah gravy's good man
is he a nashville thiel
no no he lives out of uh he's on tour
right now he's been living in a tour bus
gravy yeah yeah
okay just be responsible out there
people
yeah be responsible if you're sitting
next to somebody and you know they're a
child and you an adult then you gotta
get out the car
get out the car bro the person's acting
like a child too if they acting like a
child even if they're 25 but you'd be
like ugh this person just you know take
some responsibility for your actions
what's this thick daddy want this is our
last uh debate club
brendan theo eric
stevie the whole crew
what's up guys
uh anthony from long island new york
here
got a quick uh debate club for you guys
um
just driving you know from the highway
right now really
proud and lucky to have the freedoms
that we got here you know um
so
if you take those freedoms away
that we have here in this great country
i wanted to ask you guys debate club
where would you rather live
russia
or china
tough decision
both pretty shitty
either way you got to pick one debate
club russia or china where are you
living
gang gang buzz buzz russia all day sons
yeah
russian women i knew it i said he liked
white girls i knew vodka russian women
were in some dopes what's wrong with the
chinese women what you don't like the
chinese women i don't like the chinese
smog they got fentanyl in the tits yeah
dog
fats
it's titanol yeah chapstick with
fentanyl
i want that titan i'm just saying baby
some of the freaking you know they got
some drywall in the wetlands you know
what i'm saying let's ask chin that what
russia or china my man china
no i'll be honest russian russia he oh
he he also likes white girls
yeah he likes taylor taylor swift is his
i do like white girls i like every every
girl that's attractive but i mean
obviously he's with me man
no
i mean i've seen some pretty chinese
women but i mean as far as countries i'd
probably rather be in russia yeah yeah
maybe i'm gonna go with china man why
russia because of the chinese women
really for the women yeah name one hot
chinese woman
we got to timestamp that
who's the most famous uh like chinese
no she's korean she's korean oh no she's
japanese she's japanese
oh yeah i mean there's beautiful women
everywhere for sure yeah everywhere has
dime pieces look at most beautiful
pictures
that's great you could just google that
i'm trying to stuff looks you're looking
at all these women y'all got to back off
there you go there you go chin
look what you're missing out on chip
look what you're missing i don't know
it's the smog he's right though not
the food it's crowded as [ __ ] number one
and your woman looks more like these
guys but russia the politics in russia i
don't know
go ahead eric i don't know [ __ ] with me
man i'm just out there doing my thing i
might go to china man there you go
the iphone there's no screen you take a
picture it's just you just looking
through the phone at whatever you're
looking at
got a hand you got to hand draw it you
know i'm like
yeah i don't know i just who's number
one i think the food would be better in
china [ __ ] no
yeah food's probably awesome there fan
bing bing
dude beijing would you
pick up pictures of beijing and look how
like magnificent that city is go to hong
kong i've been there i've been to hong
kong
china owns hong kong i know but there's
just like there's really a concept it's
a very modern city though it's like the
city actually yeah you know the whatever
it is lit as [ __ ] i was in beijing three
years ago yeah he was there you go
you know i'm just talking about like and
you look at russia like dumb russia all
day yeah i'm wearing those hats look
this looks like downtown l.a or
something man look look look how many
cars yeah why wouldn't you want to know
how many people are you you can't go
anywhere doug i can't go anywhere in
your room just look how dope that city
like
me and steve going to be in china there
you go man i changed my mind now i want
to go china being russian some fur some
they're gonna be in a bread line with
that big furry thing on yeah yeah it's
cold there
you know that right it's cold in china
thick okay yeah can't handle the cold he
don't want to be in the cold is it cool
i heard him
when you look at these pictures what we
realize is that we just don't know
everywhere it's dope because i think
russia i think those weird like you know
i'm thinking it's like snowy like
siberia i'm like this looks like [ __ ]
seattle yeah
they look like toronto or something so
you know what here's what we'll do we're
gonna go six months in china and then
six months in moscow cat's on the road
yeah
yeah china russia
you know what i mean yeah baby i'm
russia all day
theory
there you go
that's it that's it
baby gang
uh that's what's up man
i'm in everett everett washington's 30
minutes outside seattle november 27th
one night only at a theater out there in
everett washington and then the new
year's i met a man i said i'm in everett
who is that ah man balls deep in everett
yeah uh uh end of the year was it
december 29th through january 1st
bringing the new year with 36 friend
here
it is basically fort lauderdale i think
it's called dania dania's fort
lauderdale improv out there get you some
then thick boy uh jerseys and merch goes
on sale uh tomorrow friday 9 a.m
thickboy.com theo we miss you dog get
your fine ass in here yes here man we
miss you too man i'm gonna be out at
spotlight casino in churchilla uh
california on
what is that date there december 4th
december 4th at 8 p.m i'm looking
forward to that uh the tickets are on
sale now and i got uh
i'm upstairs merch that's dropping this
week and um
that's it man happy to be back in in
here with you guys i had a really good
time thank you i'll be at the miami
improv this weekend great club and then
uh
and speaking of merch i made that the
homeboy reuben made uh that picture of
me with the island boys so i put them on
the shirts and it's called you a woo-woo
boy
that's funny
get out of these if you go to my uh
uh
there's a store there you can go to i
don't know if you can go to but there it
is right there i put that i'm a woo-woo
boy
i threw down on some shirts
you're looking dimed up oh i'm gonna be
in tempe in tempe improv this weekend
with jeremiah i'm doing again yeah yeah
he got to start paying you
enough of these guests
i want to ask you this tv does it feel
like you've been getting more in motion
just in your life in general in the past
four or five months oh yeah yeah
i'm so glad i started doing stand-up i'm
having fun it's like you came on king of
the scene got your [ __ ] yeah yeah i'm
having fun i'm like oh this is all my
head uh it was all in my mind
so i'm having a good experience man just
trying to learn you know love it go see
them kids we love you guys love you guys
theo see you next week doug it's
thanksgiving next week doug king in the
state
back with the crew we got stevie weeby
eric griffin brendan theo too yeah you
know how we do it so just tune in for
the laughs theo said that he was on his
way but ran out of gas
stevie weeby used to wrestle down at
parkway
now he only finished boys in the hallway
this ain't the greatest
[Music]
just walked in and got it lit you can't
forget about brendan he still need
everything thick thick they still got
the bees in the trap trapping still the
king in the sting so quit asking
if you know then you know it's a cat's
[Music]
yeah you know how we do it so just tune
in for the laughs theo said that he
[Music]
[Applause]
king and the sting